نحن عالقون نحن عالقون استراتيجيا بدون
يجد مع الحكومة وهذا يتصل بالنقطة الأخيرة
أن القدس ليست قادرة على قيادة الجيش
كما أجرينا مقابلات بالأمس فقط وليس الدولة
إلى حالة شيء حتى يبدأ في الاقتراب
للنصر مع كل الاحترام للإنجازات التكتيكية
ومن الناحية العملية، يوجد هنا رئيس وزراء وحكومة
التي تتجنب غزل أهداف الحرب السياسية
استراتيجيات لأسباب سياسية وشخصية وما شابه ذلك
هذا الشخص انتقم منا منذ اليوم الأول وهو قادم الآن
أنت حقًا لم تشعر بنوع من التقاطع
حدثني عن الوحدة التي تحدثني عنها
أهمية وضع المختطفين في الاعتبار عند
أجلس هناك في الغرفة، أنا حقًا أنت من ذوي الخبرة
كما قلت، لم تشعر أنك بخير، أريد أن أخبرك
وكان هناك نقاش لساعات من النقاش المتعمق حول المستقبل
غزة، أنتم تعلمون أن هذا الموضوع يهمني كثيراً
لسنوات عديدة قلت أيضا أشياءي
ثم في الدقائق القليلة الماضية اشترينا هذه الحجة
نحن بالتأكيد نفضل ألا يكون مفكراً
هناك قلق داخل التعويم داخل هذه الحكومة
إذا بدأوا باستجواب الجيش أو هذا إذا
لقد بدأ الجيش بالتحقيق، لذا ربما سيبدأ قريبًا أيضًا
استجوبهم وفي النهاية المسؤولية تقع على عاتق الجميع
على الجميع أن يتحمل المسؤولية، الجميع لديه ما يكفي
المسؤولية عن هذا الفشل الذريع تذهب أيضا إلى الطريق
القانون الخاص بي ينطبق أيضًا على الجيش، أعتقد أن الفارق كبير
أنه على الطريق قوانين بعض الحاضرين ليست بعد
قبول أنهم مسؤولون عن التقصير
فظيع وفي الجيش النخبة العسكرية بأكملها تعرف ذلك
كشلا تعرف أن لديها مسؤولية وتعرف ذلك في النهار
أنه بعد أن تضطر إلى العودة إلى المنزل، هذا الفهم غير موجود
لا يزال على المستوى السياسي وفي القيادة وهذا الشيء
والنتيجة المباشرة هي أنهم يتحدثون عن الوحدة وماذا
أننا شهدنا تبادلاً لإطلاق النار في نهاية الأسبوع
ثقل بين غانز ونتنياهو وجالانت أنا كثير
لسنوات عديدة في مجلس الوزراء لم يكن هناك شيء من هذا القبيل
بدلًا من الحديث عن الكيفية
نحن نغير الوضع في الشمال وكيم
في الحملة الانتخابية الآن
إنه إخوة للتقبيل، إنه إخوة لتقبيل يسمونه
لشخصيات عامة لشخصيات إعلامية وتقول ماذا
الطريقة الوحيدة لحل المشكلة هي أن تأخذنا
العودة دعونا نعيد الصراع داخل الشركة
الإسرائيليون الذين يجلسون داخل النمر ويقولون أنني يساري
أنا الجناح الأيمن لرئيس الوزراء، لذا علينا أن نمتلك السيوف
أولئك الذين يقولون دعونا ننهي الحرب يجب أن يفعلوا ذلك
إن إنهاء الحرب هو جزء من حملة تشن ضدنا
أهالي المختطفين يديرون حملة ضدنا
تحويل يقول أننا مذنبون بماذا
لا أعرف من المسؤول، لكني مررت في الشارع
من يومين واحد صرخ في وجهي خليهم يخدموا
بالفعل 140 صفيق سوف تنتهي لدي صديق
أخبرني أحد المؤرخين ذات مرة إيهود أنه سيتم استدعائك متى
يقول: سوف تطفو الجثث في الماء
التأكيد على أنه لن يتم تعويم جثث اللاجئين الأبرياء
سيتم طرح القوانين القانونية من المناطق التي ليست لعرب إسرائيل
جثث اليهود
أن اليهود
من المؤسف أنهم لم يذبحوك، من المؤسف أنهم لم يذبحوك
أنت